hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well close to the end
of his early great work the Mona loggia
and some is going to engage in a very
important line of discussion then he has
to do with our capacity to have
knowledge and to fully understand the
Divine Anselm was going to say we can't
actually fully understand the divine
which is a bit of a strange thing saying
after having gone through a rational
exposition essentially of the trini
which is you know a pretty deep and
difficult notion in Christian doctrine
so you think the dance I'm going to be
much more optimistic about the
capacities of rational argumentation
says he has just employed that for you
know dozens of chapters before then
it'll work but an summit is taking a
very important pause here and this is
rather typical of his approach he thinks
that we can use human reason to a great
extent in fact greater than many of the
other philosophers and theologians out
there you have much more confidence in
the capacities of human reason and yeah
he also thinks
it is limited but it is limited in such
a way that we human beings can make
sense out of that limited pneus
rationally at least to some extent as a
matter of fact in 64 mono melodeon 64 he
is going to speak and rather paradoxical
terms about comprehending the inning
comprehensibility of something and
that's you know rather than typical of
an Psalms approach so how does the issue
get raped it gets raised actually back
in chapter 36 which he refers back to in
chapter 64 chapter 36 had to do with the
incomprehensible way in which the word
expresses and also knows or really those
are the same thing all created in and
the Anselm says well you know we can we
can rationally you know get to the point
where we we understand and we explain
that this is the case but precisely how
it is the case you know what the divine
wisdom is in itself that's not something
that we can we can fully understand and
even the degree to which we can get it
is rather rather limited so in chapter
64 he's going to talk about a was
translated here is mystery ass accattone
so sublime a matter exceeding or
transcending the actual word that he
uses their science transcanada the power
of human understanding so that's one
side that right that sounds like well we
can't really know that much about God
when it comes down to it and yet at the
same time like it says we have been able
to rationally examine and understand the
the nature of the divine we've done
quite a lot less so let's go take a
little closer look at what
saying here he says I think someone
investigating an incomprehensible thing
we want to be satisfied if his reasoning
arrives at the knowledge that the thing
will certainly exist even if his
understanding cannot fathom how it is so
he actually goes beyond they have just
that it does exist he says nor should we
withhold any the certainty of faith from
beliefs that are asserted on the basis
of necessary proofs and contradicted by
no other argument he doesn't actually
use the term argument there he talks in
terms of reasons necessary reasons we've
employed that to make sense out of the
the nature of the divine substance so he
says now what is incomprehensible as
ineffable as the one who is above all
things therefore of the conclusions we
have reached thus far concerning the
supreme essence have been asserted on
the basis of necessary reasons they're
solid certainty has no way shaken even
though the understanding cannot fathom
them so as to be able to explain them in
words and he says for if earlier a
reflection that was rationally
comprehends it's incomprehensible how
will that supreme wisdom knows the
things he made you know he goes on
further the key issue here is that we
can in fact understand to some degree we
can use reason to penetrate into the
secret of the mystery the ultimately for
us in comprehensibility that in itself
in comprehensibility or the enough
ability the inability to actually say
what the thing is to talk about it
meaningfully we can use our Faculty of
reason to to make some progress into
that but it's always sort of contingent
progress even though it seems to be
totally necessary in another word the
courteous homo written much later on and
some will say that
necessary reasons might be necessary
from our perspective but not truly
necessary and this is a conception that
he has run throughout his works so when
we go to chapter 65 where the solution
to this is could be he's going to
reframe the problem how can something be
an affable and yet rationally understood
this is important because you know when
we're talking about something being
rationally understood we mean that we're
able to bring some intelligibility to it
or penetrate into the intelligibility of
that thing so if we've been talking
about the divine all this time what have
we been doing are we just you know
spinning our wheels so he in some is
going to make it important distinction
here and this is one again that runs
throughout it works one I think that
there's quite you know easy to grasp for
most of us there is explaining the
manner to some degree and they use that
word explicar very there but you could
also use the word you know to reason
about to understand and telling thing
and that's that's a you know quantum as
if I remember right to to some degree
right and then there's a diff that's
distinct from from fully comprehending a
thing so you know think about for
example the way it works with with
medicine you probably understand some
basics of medicine they are actually
pretty far advanced if we compare them
to what they had in hansoms time you
know you understand how the blood
circulates you understand how nerves
work you understand you know how
sicknesses of a loose of certain sorts
can be combated then you've probably got
that from health class or reading things
on the internet who knows right people
telling you does that mean that your
doctor know and let's say soon to take
doctors right there's an old joke what
do you call the person who graduated
last in their medical
class doctor presumably they don't know
quite so much yes the person who
graduated first and goes on to an
illustrious career and a great residency
at all levels certain things so there
thurs degrees in understanding and it's
the same way with the divine now we're
not talking about as medicine which by
itself is a pretty murky topic right
we're talking about something that
totally transcends the entire created
universe is it reasonable to expect that
we could fully comprehend it no as a
matter of fact if we the more we think
about it what's logically it is that
that we're going to have that sort of
hubris so he says if the Supreme essence
is so much above and beyond every other
nature then even if sometimes words are
applied to him that are common to other
nature's maybe their meetings are in no
way common he's suggesting that there
may be an equal varsity here in the way
in which we use words of the divine and
of the creative beings we talk about
wisdom is the divine wisdom like human
wisdom just to the enth degree just
amped up a whole bunch that's not really
applicable he says if the familiar
meaning of words then becomes from for
him right none of my reasoning applies
to you how then is it true that
something has been discovered about the
supreme essence if what has been
discovered is vastly different from them
my my rational understanding that I'm
conveying in this book in an Psalms case
to us the readers but also to himself
through his own reason because these are
meditations those are not the same thing
as the Divine Being and there's sort of
a disconnect there between the words and
concepts that we're using to describe
God and the reality of God this is part
of what it means to go God ineffable so
what is the solution here Ansem gives it
so making a likeness a cymol tune in a
civil to Nanette simple to today right
about likenesses an image of an image so
there's a bit of medisoft going on here
he says that we express many things not
just about the divine by many things
about mundane matters in the ways that
that are not relying on the distinct
characteristics of the thing itself but
rather through some sort of likeness or
a real or an image right he says we
often say many things we do not properly
express as they really are and you know
you have the entire range of metaphor
that we use many of which are our old
metaphors that we don't even recognize
think about business speaking and how
much they like to make references to
metaphorical things like we're going to
drill down are you drilling or you
actually drilling down into the data
that you're looking at no it's a
metaphor it's conveying something
through an image that is supposed to
connote you know a sense of seriousness
or getting to the depth of things the
irony of course is that do people who
say drill down or off and you know the
most superficial fingers right then it
will be something else five years from
now so we express things through through
something else quite often now when we
turn to God he says what we say about
God and that includes everything in this
book what we say about God is more
through images then through what what
translating here is God's distinctive
character of essence through you know
his propria talks ascent TI the the you
know what is actually distinctive to
God's being what is specific to God to
be that is not something that we can
express as such in words that are
actually
adequate to their referent and so we do
convey things through images even when
we're carrying out rational examination
of these theological you know objects or
truths so he says we say in see through
some other thing we do not state or see
through its own distinctive character
and he says here we go by this argument
it's perfectly possible for our
conclusions thus far about the supreme
nature to be true and yet for that
nature himself nevertheless to remain
ineffable if we suppose that he was in
no way expressed through the distinctive
character of his essence but somehow
designated through some other thing and
he gets some examples here the words
that seem applicable to that nature do
not show him to me through his
distinctive character so much as they
hint at him through some lightness what
are the examples of that divine wisdom
you know we don't actually fandom the
totality of the divine wisdom we get a
little hint of it and we you know we
make sense of it by using a word that we
use about other people's wisdom right
and it's not totally adequate but it
gets the job done to a certain extent so
he says by their meaning they produce
something in my mind that is much less
than that is in fact vastly different
from that which my mind is trying to
come to understand through their tenuous
signification now what is what is one of
the implications of this when we're
doing rational theology like ants on
this do it we're not generating
something that would be ecstatic set of
propositions that then we've got and
this is God right this is not the what's
often called the god of the
Philosopher's the guy who is merely just
a being who is described by a set of
propositions that are assumed to be
adequate then this implies they have the
human being in order to
understand God to the degree that the
human being is going to be able to
understand God is going to have to
continue to remain in an active process
of seeking which makes perfect sense for
his audience which is a bunch of monks
so this is his resolution of this
problem how is it we're able to say
anything about the incomprehensible
ineffable inevitable ineffable sorry God
well we designate the divine through
images then don't provide us with the
totality of God but a hint they provide
clues about the nature of the divine